turning now to that fiery trained
derailment on the Ohio Pennsylvania
border officials announcing yesterday
that they had successfully conducted
what they're calling a controlled
release of toxic chemicals chemicals
could have caused an explosion if left
unchecked but there are still more
dangers ahead and Roxanna Roxanna saberi
joins us now from Columbiana Ohio that
is just a few miles west of where the
Train derailed Roxanna good morning
Good morning Tony this is where First
Responders and the National Guard have
been Gathering there are no reports yet
of injuries or deaths but last night we
smelled a strong odor in the air and
it's unclear how far the fumes have
spread and how toxic they are
a plume of smoke erupted into the skies
surrounding East Palestine Ohio Monday
afternoon
after authorities released toxic fumes
from five derailed train cars to avoid
what they warned what would have been an
even greater threat the railroad has a a
serious concern about an explosion with
one or more of these cars earlier in the
day Ohio Governor Mike dewine told CBS
news that anyone refusing to leave the
evacuation Zone before the controlled
release could also be at risk of
inhaling the fumes you know if you're
within a close proximity you know you
very well could die the five cars were
carrying Vinyl chloride which is used to
make a variety of plastics it's a highly
combustible chemical linked to an
increased risk of certain cancers
according to the National Cancer
Institute so far the federal EPA says it
has as expected found some Airborne
contamination near the burn location but
did not give a measure for the amount or
any effects as for the water officials
previously said some runoff has been
detected in surround founding streams
but that they're working to stem it and
there's been no impact on drinking water
so far you can just see a haze on the
water that's nasty and you can smell it
but local resident Russell Murphy says
he's already seen hundreds of dead fish
in a river just miles from the
derailment site and it's concerned about
what could potentially come next the
health effects the long-term
environmental effects the waterways I
mean this is bad
yeah
Federal investigators say mechanical
issues with a rail car axle appeared to
have caused the derailment Governor
dewine told CBS News there's no timeline
yet for when residents can go home Gail
all right Roxanna thank you very much